bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono fa vj ed oggi siamo un nuovo
video con locke lustri ragazzi che
praticamente è un pezzo non ne facciamo
con la crus mi sono dimenticato quanto è
bello proprio comunque ragazzi il video
sarà lo vedete voi stessi perché [ __ ]
tutto vento ragazzi siamo su su cyber
face
ma che cosa fa questo
[Musica]
ragazzo tizio bellissimo che balla causa
stavolta è displays lager noi che poi
far poi cosa stai facendo no va bene
ovviamente ragazzi un gioco dove c'è una
giostra tipo che cazzo annunciò la testa
io sono un tizio senza testa fantastico
tardiva se vuoi l'altro che io sono
affari j e comunque piace a non si è
occupata me non la fa niente siamo in
massa e la madonna
qua siamo in paradiso credete in realtà
a ziama livelli stipsi ptc coperti risto
gioco bellissimo tipo stata ok quella
mudhoney già mi sento che regala fuori
chiostri ma anche alla testa rega non è
normale è stato mi dà un effetto di tv
atto pazzesco bella macchina o il cristo
di dio
la donna ma mi chiamo i fan mi andavo
mita senti zia ma lo sai che mi fa
girare la testa nella maniera
incredibile azione
ma [ __ ] avrà fatto fare di questo
schifo no ragazzi mi chiami giochi no no
no no no no no no
sono io sono vivo vivo non vendo un
cazzo ricavo che ho chiuso gli occhi
anche se voi non vedete non la vedete
sono 21 media zia lo vedi benissimo dove
si spegne lo schifo il ragazzo è certo
bellissimo sporca la [ __ ] macchiato
il cazzo ti guardi donna e brutti
bruttissimi non regga e bruttissimo
giuro mi min fa venire le vertigini una
maniera pazzesca ma chi è che fa sti
giochi mi chiami venda vomitare lega
basta ho detto basta
senti via
mi fa male da te basta qui si spegne
basta non c'è un tasto gente non c'è più
premi tutta sola riga buongiorno della
nokia sentito non ti piacciono ai beni
march quelli che non ci hanno paura
tutto ha paura di niente non ho paura di
niente
io santo no vabbè ma basta come si
spegne seriamente di far mi viene la
frutta cos'è sto cos'è dove sono girato
al contrario giusto madonna da madonna
fermi kakà de silvestri 6
basta basta co sto sto male sto
malissimo anche brutto pavimento che ci
ha limato il pezzo ma si ferma stagista
prima poi continua così per tutta la
vita sono ragazzi rimarrò su questa
merda finché non muoio son convince non
è possibile
vai tu c'hai questa qua si fa i giri al
contrario e non fa un cazzo di sorriso
nel non fare niente
cioè divi israele
basta basta la vedo proprio che
spaventata come la porca [ __ ]
no ragazzi in basta basta basta ma mi
sto scassato il cazzo come si toglie si
toglie in qualche modo sito non è
possibile sono stretti che sto qui
allora c'è un tasto per fermare il suo
schifo da qualche parte non lo so questo
no [ __ ] c'è casa mia ragazzi che
belle è bellissimo la vedo da qua sconta
più definito e finito mi sembra finito
si si si si io soldi tu io ho passato la
giornata di merda della mia vita e tu
balli belle signore è stato bellissimo
avete avuto la fortuna di stare vicino a
un marcelo ma grazie successo ragazzi o
sonoro sono morto ma si può morire il
suo gioco lo sapevo amico mio so che
vuoi far colpo su ste belle ragazze come
la tua danza sexy però non è il momento
che c'è ancora il mio sangue a terra si
sa con la femmina consenta a lanciarmi
prima dopo io voglio provare a lanciarmi
perché non posso come è assurdo
ok siete pronti ragazze
siamo solo vivo vivo manco per il caso
però la donna mia un chilometro
cioè non lo sapevo che si poteva fare
sta stronzata fatevela fargli muover che
l'obiettivo è centrare la macchina
ragazzi che a camin attimo che bastiamo
ancora testo adesso sta provando con
azoto volando accanto a drogarsi stop
cuccioli perfetto verso l'infinito e
oltre
[Musica]
ok non è non è stato proprio il massimo
però quanto cazzo è alto ma vi rendete
conto
ragazzi lascio perdere qui perché è
stato alquanto brutto come come cosa mi
sono ucciso diverse
inizia [ __ ] bella sarda di appagare
in mano nostra
accordo ragazzi è stato bellissimo
soprattutto per i miei capelli giocare
questi videogame call of nutrition
comunque è stato stupendo tipo andare
ancora vomitare però con calma lasciamo
perdere che c'è un mal di testa
dell'amat mi ha fatto venire
vi giuro che mi ha fatto venire mal di
testa di solo un motivo se non faccio
giochi del loculo striscia ogni 5
fottuti minuti con ragazzi servito è
piaciuto e se siete anche voi contro le
giostre brutte lasciando un commento mi
piace anche a face di facebook e come
ogni video trattate sezione senza
dovresti si è felici di vediamo il
prossimo video era ragazzi